now you look at somebody like fauci
it looks like nothing's gonna happen to
him at all the these guys nothing
there's no accountability whatsoever
even small things the the mayor of uh
san francisco puts the entire city on
lockdown and she puts a mask mandate out
and then she's out there dancing and
drinking and partying with no mask
whatsoever i mean how do you handle
something like that where you were held
accountable but but these people that
hold the rest of us accountable face no
accountability in themselves well let me
let me answer that a little bit
i've never seen the mafia be a predator
against society
we stalled we made money we killed one
another because of rules in our
organization we didn't go out killing
innocent men women children
i mean like people that are outside the
mafia outside of the mafia
and
we didn't do certain things we took a
piece of things that in industries but
we took a piece
these people don't give a [ __ ] about
nobody
they take the whole pie
one two
they don't care about men women or
children and innocent people
there's a complete difference
they're nothing like the mafia talk
about the government
the the people who yes the government
and politicians do you think they care
uh the media even some of the media
people who are out there today
do they care you go to college you go to
universities you all your life you're
gonna be out there you're gonna hold the
powerful
hold their feet to the fire are they
doing that no
so
what happened
what is happening
and how do you stop it
that's the whole thing so this
technology went patrick and we went into
a whole frenzy about what's going on but
this technology i think it's good
and it has a bad side i don't know if
it's all that good
they're teaching
race theory in prison in schools
i mean i don't i don't get that either
critical race there crt which is just
watered down marxism
well it's racism because if you're white
and your grandfather owned something or
did something then you're no good
i mean i don't get it my i don't even
know my great grandfather i don't know
what he did or what he didn't do
i don't give two [ __ ] what he did
has nothing to do with me
i know what my mother did i know what my
father did
they were far from being racist
look what they did with jews they they
loved them
huh or rich grew up middle class
brooklyn just like you know everybody
else you know it's like you you weren't
down in the south running the plantation
you know like what do you hold a held
accountable for and i don't think even
those people i don't knock those people
that was the time and that's what they
did
and racism didn't start
with bringing blacks into white people
didn't bring blacks into this country
and use them as slaves like it's the
histories where did they come from
started in africa
the strong african tribes grabbed
strong
men and women and sold them in africa
shippers who went there said
wow this is we can make a lot of money a
guy looks like a strong guy we could
sell him he could be a worker somewhere
that's how it started
it started with black people doing it
against black people
and then it went all around the world
with shippers and whatever this isn't a
thing that some kid is born today
whether they're latin
whether they're white whatever they are
they're not guilty of anything you can
still feel bad for who it happened to
without saying you know any of you of
course you could of course you could and
and when you're wiping out history
that's why they want to wipe out history
because this is what it really was
so of course you can feel bad
i would hate that i would hate to see
that i have a ton of black friends i
just was on gangster chronicles i was
treated like a king with them the same
type of environment all black guys
joke and laugh and we had a great time
of course i feel bad what they did then
but that's why you want history
you want to change it
vietnam
we went there they were telling me when
i was a kid training
they're going to come here they're going
to rape your mom your sisters they're
going to kill us they're going to do
this they're saying
kong was going to come here and do that
that was the propaganda that you were
being served that's what i was training
on the oh well but that's [ __ ] i
don't know of one vietnamese guy
or a woman who's bad the only vietnamese
woman i know they do your nails they do
your toenails your fingernails they're
polite
they're good people when we left that
country
that country never did anything it got
better
so it was all [ __ ]
so what we're doing now we're [ __ ]
with countries all over the place for
what
with iran korea this one that one
all these countries afghanistan
where the [ __ ] are we where are we going
with this technology and everything
we're doing this technology we just
killed
innocent people the guy was had water
drums because he's a humanitarian for
people who didn't have water
and seven kids 10 people legitimate
people we killed
so now
and we'll just put that on the back
burner that don't mean nothing how do
you think those people are going to feel
they're going to love us
they're families they got lost
families they're going to hate us and
and we're doing these things now
i go with the metoo movement you pat a
girl on the ass
oof
you're in trouble
me too will go crazy on you
where the [ __ ] is the nato movement
about these girls and women
that are about to be slaughtered in
afghanistan what does the metoo movement
stop at the border
what about all those people
what are these people in the border here
i don't know what's going on in this
country i'll tell you the truth i look
at this border
we open up the border
it's a million
and a half plus people
got in there ready
i gotta wear a mask
take shots do this do that they don't
have to wear a mask they don't have to
take shots
they don't have to be tested they can
put on buses they're shipped all over
the country
i feel sorry for them when i see them
coming through the water old lady little
kids and this and that
but i feel kind of sorry for the whole
country for us
when do we care about us well sammy you
let's use your knowledge of history
maybe to our advantage for us that
weren't around when you were a kid
if i ain't that [ __ ] no
you said you
yeah about history
i'm not gonna ask you about julius
caesar here i don't want to know about
marcus aurelius here i want to all right
guys when you were a kid
uh
in in
juniors in the 60s is that fair to say
all right all right i mean things
couldn't have been any worse jfk
assassination mlk assassination
bobby kennedy uh sirhan sirhan just got
out of jail after 50 freaking years
you were a kid growing up race relations
you know
race riots race riots
uh civil rights movement everything was
going on
is it fair to say that we're
we're doing better now than than then i
mean it's crazier things are now let me
give you a little example of that yes we
had a thing with the italian people the
italian american civil rights league
we had big rallies
a hundred thousand people
not one window was broken not one person
in the streets was beaten up not one cop
was assaulted
a hundred thousand
there was irish jewish italian people
there was every nation but joe columbo
did get shot but that's by a guy
who yeah a radical nut shot
but i'm saying the people a hundred
thousand of them
there was nothing
so we have somebody gets shot a black a
black guy they put his knee on his neck
which is horrible as soon as i saw it i
said that's a disgrace
this guy's the cop his life is over
for what he did and what i watched
the other three cops are schmucks
just watching him just watching him
you're a cop take out your gun to your
fellow cop and tell him get your [ __ ]
knee off his neck or i'll [ __ ] shoot
you get it off
that's what you should've did
you didn't
so you're just as much to blame not as
much but you should be fired and thrown
out you're not a cop
you're not a good cop anyway but to
gerrard's point
it seems like back then
public figures were being assassinated
like you said the colombo jfk mlk now
it's just
everyday citizens getting shot
and it's everyday citizens getting knee
on their neck it's actually why is that
so different
public fears aren't getting assassinated
germany just actually doesn't have to do
with america but it's to your point
germany actually just disbanded
their highest level of
government police what we would consider
like state police because they said that
they had an unfriendly opinion of the
elites
that was the actual excuse that they
gave to disband it they had an
unfriendly opinion of the elites so the
elites just got rid of them
so yeah it's upside down it used to be
the civilians holding the elites
accountable now it's the elites holding
the civilians at bay it's a very strange
time certainly have shifted yeah it's
almost back to being futile listen all
those people you said kennedy got shot
yeah
i saw the whole country crying right
when he got shot
i don't see no revolution i didn't see
wars i didn't see riots i didn't see
anything
i seen people white people all kinds of
people crying this was a shame he was a
good man
i didn't see riots i didn't see nothing
all of a sudden
now everything is right well let's not
forget these people are paid to riot
yeah well they're paid in some people
who's
paying them how come we never figured
that out no we know who they are
there's that guy who's from another
country george soros
we know who this guy is see that's the
difference with a mafia dude
now
if the mafia had something to do with
this that guy would be dead
soros yeah without a doubt mafia would
whack him in [ __ ] two seconds you
ain't doing this to us in our country
we had neighborhoods we lived in we
protected people those jews living on
the side of us you couldn't [ __ ] with
them with me sitting in the middle or my
father or the whole
neighborhood it didn't it didn't happen
we had black people in in living in our
neighborhood small little church good
people we couldn't [ __ ] with them
we wouldn't allow it you couldn't come
into a neighborhood and rape our
women yeah or kill a kid or be a
pedophile we would kill you took you
took care of your neighborhoods we took
out we did we did business we took care
of our neighborhood they were our people
we loved them all yeah it was a whole
thing with my father except for people
who are rapists or child molesters or
something like that women love them yeah
and these these things so he could if he
paid to come and create a ride in our
neighborhood bro he better stay out of
the country
so i don't even know how a guy gets away
with it or fouchy all these people doing
these things how are they getting away
with it
you couldn't get away with it years ago
or in certain mafia areas
but yet these so-called legitimate
people
uh are better than the mafia
and and this is happening i i don't get
it did you see what happened in ducktown
philadelphia it's it's impossible to
find the video but to your point they
were rioting in uh in philadelphia and
then they got down to ducktown and there
was a whole bunch of people out there
with bats and then out there in their in
their uh in their guinea teas their wife
beaters and it was white guys black guys
and they were all you know going uh
black lives matter was going nuts and
they just stood there and they were like
you guys aren't coming down this block
they were like what do you mean when i
come down this block and they're like
you're not coming down this block
this is not the riot goes that way it
doesn't come this way and they stopped
them and there was like three black
dudes that were standing with them and
they were like you guys are gonna you
know basically they would it was very
very vulgar but they were like you guys
are gonna take his side they were like
yeah absolutely you crossed this line
you're in our territory we're gonna bust
you up and that was it now that was on
the news for about 30 seconds and it was
never played again because that was the
blueprint for the rest of the country of
how they should handle this
how they should handle this they
realized that they they put it out there
on the news because it was salacious and
everybody they were going to get a lot
of views and then they took it off the
news and it's almost impossible to find
online because that is the blueprint for
how you do it just fighting back not
taking it hey here's the deal exactly
there's the line in the center
brought up the same situation next is
your decision right
listen i came out of prison i went and i
lived in a regular neighborhood in
arizona
they probably said oh [ __ ] here goes the
neighborhood
everybody blows their horn
waves to me sees me neighbor comes in i
saw you sammy you won i made stew would
you like him i mean i get along with
everybody
they they know that i'm i might be
dangerous i might whatever
but but i'm not now but
they all accepted me like
it was perfect neighborly yeah they knew
actually they came to me once or twice
they rented a house some guys and
rented the house
and they were loud with music and this
and that so i said what do you want me
to do well could you talk to them
i says
i'll think about it
and i did go and talk with them
and i said bro
the people they that i talk with them
they're going to call the cops
so you got a choice
calm it down
and why are you talking to me
i'm trying to do you a favor
be quiet
in certain hours these people got to
sleep they got to live they got kids
calm it down
guys watch your mind your business
these kids are telling you this one kid
college kids whatever one kid yeah well
i don't know if it's college they look
like [ __ ] idiots to me but
one kid wanted my bad business
i said listen bro
i'm gonna tell you
i'm i'm talking to you nice telling you
you could get in trouble with the cops
i might tell you something else bro i
don't even like the way you talk
maybe [ __ ] the cops
maybe i'll take this as a problem my
problem and your problem
we could do that
another guy tells him
oh hey bro i think that sent me the bull
he
got all fuzzed up with that [ __ ]
backed up and he stopped
they stopped
the neighbors love me they think i'm
[ __ ] god to them
but i didn't do it in an intimidating
way i didn't like to tell them
i don't know what to tell them i didn't
want to threaten them until they start
giving me stupid answers well how do you
how do you handle the internet comments
then man you're such a guy with respect
you're so old school with respect i mean
the comment section must be i don't even
bother i have
you know like we go off have these tech
guys around us i got a 99 point
something rate of positive things so
you're going to get these little creeps
sitting in the basement
and texting
you know this guy's a creep and this
guy's no good i'm sure patrick has some
[ __ ]
he's a good man he probably don't have
it but everybody has somebody who wants
to be a little creep in the basement
they get off on it i don't even bother
with them
[Music]
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]
you